How can women who waited too long to
have children find meaning in their lives
once they realized their mistake?
How can we cope with the regret?
Jesus?
That's a hard question.
Well,
you know,
there are other avenues to meaning,
right?
I mean,
that's,
that's the first thing to
realize is that there are,
there's intimate relationship,
there's familial relationships that
aren't in accordance with children.
There's other people that you can serve.
There are other children
that you can serve.
So what you have to do,
because intimate relationships
are so important,
and I'm including that close familial,
I'm not talking about
sexual relationships.
I'm talking about very
close social relationships.
The thing about having children,
if you're lucky,
is that you have a relationship there
of a depth that you don't get anywhere
else with the possible exception of your
parents and siblings and your partner.
But there's something about the child
relationship that's even more fundamental
because the thing about having a
child is that if you have any sense,
as soon as you have a child,
you are no longer the
most important person,
right?
You're no longer the person that
you have primary responsibility for.
It's now your child.
And that produces a
psychological transformation
and it produces a relationship
of a depth that can't be
easily duplicated elsewhere.
But it's not like that's the only
thing that there is to do in life.
You know,
there,
there are other relationships and I would
say what you do is you foster them to
the degree that that's possible.
And maybe you could find
other kids to serve.
You know,
there's always the possibility
of volunteering for hospitals or,
or,
or working in places where
children need service.
So that's a possibility as well.
And so you've,
you know,
there are,
there are a variety of sources of
meaning in people's lives and they're,
they're not unlimited.
You know,
there's career,
there's education,
there's what you do that's meaningful,
meaningfully engages you outside of work.
There's your social relations,
your friends and so forth.
And so maybe you have five lakes lakes
to stand on and you missed one cause he
didn't have kids.
Or maybe you miss too
because kids are a big deal.
But that doesn't mean the rest
of them aren't accessible to you.
And so you optimize your functioning
along the dimensions that are left to you.
And then I would also say maybe you
tried to forgive yourself a little bit.
You know,
like it's very difficult
to go through life without
yeah.
Without regrets,
without making mistakes.
You know,
when you can't beat yourself to death
for it because then everyone would beat
themselves to death all the time.
And so you think,
well that's,
that's I've,
I'm,
I'm too soon old and too late wise
to use an old cliche and you think,
well that's the law of mankind.
We learn things too late
often and that's too bad.
And you forgive yourself because you're
stupid and you don't know what you're
doing and you're unwise
just like everyone else.
And maybe you're somewhat capable
of learning if you're careful.
And then you go out and you try to foster
and do good in the world to the degree
that you can outside of the necessity of,
of children.
And maybe you have nephews,
nieces,
and you can lavish some attention on
them and find your substitute where you
can.
But I would say to forgive
yourself is a big part of that.
It's like people make mistakes,
mad big mistakes.
And the people that I've watched
through life that have been successful,
it's not like they didn't make mistakes
because everyone makes mistakes and they
do things they regret and
they miss opportunities and
it's a bloody catastrophe,
but they treat themselves with some
degree of mercy along with the justice.
It's like,
yeah,
well I screwed up there and I'm going to
try to learn and I'm not going to do it
again,
but I'm not going to beat myself to
death so that I can't get up again.
And so you do what you
can to forgive yourself.
You know,
it's a confusing time to live in in many
ways because we have the birth control
pill now and that means reproduction
has now become voluntary.
Well,
when's a good time to reproduce?
never,
because who would ever
think about doing that?
It's so ridiculously irrational
and complicated and the
burden of responsibility
is so insanely high and
you never secure enough to,
to have the proper place to
bring children into the world.
And you have to get your
career going and your,
and your intimate relationship.
And maybe you have some struggle doing
that and one day you wake up and it's a
bit late.
It's like,
yeah,
well you're a product of your time.
And one of the prices that we're going
to pay for having birth control for
having reliable contraception is that
some people are going to make the wrong
decision with regards to having children.
And then you view yourself
as a product of your time.
And that's a catastrophe,
you know,
because to be a product of your
time is in some ways a catastrophe.
So,
but there's other things
to do in life and,
and augering yourself into
the ground with regret and,
and,
and self recrimination is not useful.
Right?
I mean,
you have to learn your lesson,
you have to take your lumps,
all of that,
but have some mercy.
You know?
That's,
it.